hello and welcome to CEO playing volley
from India I've never played it before
that's interesting so let's see okay
take that and check on recommending to
get the pawn back immediately I think
this is a good idea and Queen to be
three I think it's also better hear that
Quincy too I think I'm okay we'll see
here and monster prepares c5 quickly not
be seven now we go see five immediately
this is very early and okay i wonder if
i take hmm the single night BTW 700 what
is the deal here Bishop takes I'm quite
happy with but night BTW 7 i'm not quite
sure about Toby should be three okay
shouldn't shouldn't think for too long
ok so here I think a for should be quite
ok
just looking to attack be 5 km let's go
Bishop g5 night PT 2 nite c for this
kind of thing I don't want to take down
rookie wonder screen to be six so it's
not that great ok I'm happy to do that
ok I'm i think night you wanna i want to
bring this night to d3 anyway and those
bishops have to be traded a night on d3
the other well on f3 usually but you can
also think about 94 here he bra a hand
no of course not why this better in this
position just a matter how much better
so I then go here to preempt any queen b
76
why don't I take the rook here I can
take the damn rope and his his draw for
really irritated me somehow I can just
take the bloody rope oh my god okay okay
it's a good position anyway but Luke is
the rookies rook I should take it
so let's see here Quincy 61 possible
option I think I'll go for that just
attack the pawn the night here is a lot
stronger than the bishop the bishop is
just looking at a completely empty
diagonal and it takes nothing I can also
store do be three in this position which
would help to make the night even more
stable but it fades some options like
going with a king to be three in an
ending but okay I still probably will
play be three just to be sure that I'm
not blundering some stuff okay so just
be 34 potentially Queen to be six so
look blundering be too so Queen B 6 you
might check me out this is a little bit
so maybe I'll go out out avoid the check
so what I'm trying to say here also
group d 6 comes into consideration
attacking a six and if you take syd take
a 6-0 it
so one that pawn to double here on the D
file and the bishop is a fairly useless
PCM so one of those cases where Bishop
is really doing not much at all so how
to do the screen to have three years
maybe an idea for him or queen f5 to see
to maybe prevent Queen f3 just also
prevent the other idea kingi to king a
queen f3 and then March the a porn
something like that is technically and
think called form
ok also go to f4 that's a good idea
yeah Quinn to it towards what he tries
to do um yeah this still takes a while
yeah I can let's just push the ape on it
should be should be quick enough really
Queen a 4 equals back can also go here
no I cannot go there let's go to our 47
might be 6 I just don't take the
material in this game I can take I could
take material the whole time again again
I can do this and in the wind stuff and
some I don't really a bit strange I here
actually whupped his seven as possible
for him so Knight b6 wasn't a good move
time morning so look da droop t8 and
let's not lose on time look on the
seventh night c4 back and then a six and
stuff ok 44 seconds okay
96 also also coming here check check
this is the easiest our thing
technically check check check
does he get a knight now what's happen
again checkmate okay Wow sometimes I
really wonder what why do I have to make
it so difficult and taking the rook for
example would have been pretty nice oops
it's funny that the engine doesn't
understand the position that's really
funny it gives us as equal which is
wrong and why this is a bit better here
because black has a Rico inside okay so
here and yeah I just play Queen aat and
it's over you can't just take the bloody
rook now came I was just in technical
mode and that draw what really irritated
me yeah this is a fairly typical Catalan
position where things are not really
great for black those pawns are weak and
this Bishop is entirely useless it just
points into into emptiness it's very
comfortable for wide yum yum at the end
he dropped this pawn and I only missed
something later not be six year would
have been a bit easier and just just
grab the exchange but ok ok here Queen
upset that was a nice one check ok yeah
Knight b6 actually was pretty terrible
yeah it was pretty terrible move because
this isn't all that clear right here I
can do this but it gets complicated and
it shouldn't be and here again i miss
Queen f7
but okay I saw that this ending is a win
and it didn't look much much further
Jack McCann cannot defend this ending ok
so I'm about 2,500 again tough thanks
for watching